these are some of the most recent
pictures from tigre
but they are weeks old the region is
quite deliberately it seems being cut
off from the rest of the world
the un believes famine has already taken
hold but humanitarian access remains
severely limited and now the ethiopian
government in a tweet has announced it's
expelling seven top u.n officials they
have 72 hours to leave the country in
response a spokesperson for the u.n
secretary general read out this
statement he's issued
i was shocked by the information that
the government of ethiopia has declared
seven u.n officials including senior u.n
humanitarian officials as personnel
non-grata
i have full confidence in the u.n staff
who are in ethiopia doing this work the
un is committed to helping ethiopian
people who rely on humanitarian
assistance we are now engaging with the
government of ethiopia in the
expectation that the concerned u.n staff
will be allowed to continue their
important work
at the un security council ambassadors
viewed the planned expulsions as the
most unwelcome development
do you believe this expulsion of the top
u.n staff is part of an attempt by the
ethiopian government to use starvation
as a weapon
look like the secretary general i'm
deeply shocked by what we've just heard
about the expulsion of senior
humanitarian
workers you've heard me time and again
here raise our concerns about tiggery
now i would say about northern ethiopia
with 400 000 people now facing famine
that's more than
the rest of people facing family in the
world so we've got a real humanitarian
emergency we've been working now for
almost a year since the conflict started
to get humanitarian access in to try and
bring the parties to peace so i think
the latest developments will only
intensify intensified determination to
try and get a breakthrough several
security council members have told me
they'd like to discuss these latest
developments as soon as possible i'm
told a meeting could happen as early as
friday james bay's al jazeera of the
united nations